the world is at war but it didn't begin
with a battle
it began with hope I snuck him out of
the lab to save his wife hey smart one a
fake are you going to name Caesar humans
Illya it could control nature we gave
Caesar to therapy that allows the brain
to repair it a cure to Alzheimer's Oh
Caesar continues to show cognitive
skills that far exceed that of a human
counterpart it's wrong well it works
some things on men to be changed what
was thought to be a miracle cure been a
complication
created a virus that made humans weaker
and ace smart action on people you know
[ __ ] it
they stinking for the ACE look to Caesar
to lead them
ha
simian virus spread me of projected
colleges elevation 550 million of humans
died the virus created by scientists in
a lab they can't blame me
some believed they could exist together
we both have families you want to
protect yours I want to protect mine
it's not only chance for peace future
others believed only one civilization
could survive
are you aware no they are going to turn
on you
yeah you're all poison a man like you is
not young humans more than Apes if you
threaten his family he will retell you
don't sure what are you doing I'm sorry
flash Fred
war has begun the world fell into
further chaos now the fate of the planet
will finally be decided we are not
savages
they fight only to survive we created
them so now we will bring it in to their
kind
I did not start this war but I will
finish it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
smart one this thing are you going to
name do they look like just a tune
you saved their lives he was remarkable
you're him their seizure free the search
tree for so long till your car we are
not savages
[Music]
99 target is dead
[Music]
prepare for them they talk too much for
me
Oh
and more apes died everyday human could
think it gets mer thank you until eight
Phenom II times when it is necessary to
abandon our humanity to say you man all
of human history has led to this moment
and if we lose
it will be a planet of eight
[Music]
whoa
you